dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here not so
long ago we talked about the technique
that enabled us to render stunningly
high-quality cloth models in real time
it's supported level of detail self
shadowing and lots of other goodies that
make computer game developers and of
course my humble self super happy and
today we are going to talk about the
technique that is able to create these
highly detailed cloth geometries for our
digital characters I have really fond
memories of attending to the talk of the
Oscar Award winner Steve Martian er on
this paper a few years ago in
Switzerland and I remember being so
spellbound by it that I knew this was a
day I will never forget I am sure you'll
love it too in this piece of work the
goal is to create a digital garment
model that is as detailed and realistic
as possible we start out with an input
3d geometry that shows the rough shape
of the model then we pick an earring
pattern of our choice after that the
points of this knitting pattern are
moved so that they correctly fit this 3d
geometry that we specified and now comes
the coolest part what we created so far
is an ad hoc model that doesn't really
look and behave like a real piece of
cloth to remedy this a physics based
simulation is run that takes this ad hoc
model in the output of this process will
be a realistic rest shape for these yarn
curves and here you can witness how the
simulated forces pull the entire piece
of garment together we start out with
dreaming up a piece of cloth geometry
and this simulator gradually transforms
it into a real-world version of that
this is a step that we call yarn level
relaxation wow these final results look
not only magnificent but in a physical
simulation they also behave like real
garments it's such a joy to look at
results like this loving it again I
would like to note that we are not
talking about the visualization of the
garment but creating a realistic piece
of geometry the most obvious drawback of
this technique is its computation time
it was run on a very expensive system
and still took several
hours of number crunching to get this
done however I haven't seen an
implementation of this on the graphics
card yet so if someone can come up with
an efficient way to do it in an ideal
case we may be able to do this in
several minutes I also have to notify
you about the fact that it is considered
a crime not having a look at the paper
in the video description
it does not suffice to say that it is
well-written it is so brilliantly
presented it's truly a one-of-a-kind
work that everyone has to see if you
enjoyed this episode make sure to
subscribe to too many papers we'd be
happy to have you in our growing club of
fellow scholars thanks for watching and
for your generous support now see you
next time
[Music]